because I was brought onto Japanese TV
onto Mesmer sheet Adobe which is are the
biggest morning TV show and there whoa I
was like forced to like defend heat all
foreign youtubers in the name of Logan
pause you think of Logan who who are you
to burn your foreign I was a terrible
isn't it that's a line over there woody
they're terrible isn't it I just kept
saying that and they went home to Tokyo
I've done my bit was this recent all
know that was in 2018 I'm gonna say that
are you YouTube open the door to
apartment they're like are you you I
wait to do that three times till the
first ones but yeah yes Chris broad let
them into my apartment and it's real I
mean yeah I've had some pretty late cuz
I've been on Japanese TV twice right at
this point and man I don't know like
you're like you've been on Japanese TV a
few times too many times
what for every time just one was about
Briggs it they interviewed me on breaks
and they had me like pretend I was
disappointed was I was forced to step my
laptop with my head like this go looking
really a mostly made you do that
laptop right they found out because
obviously YouTube they were like oh
you're a youtuber hold a camera as well
while you're doing it holding a camera
be like yeah it's terrible
is the economy that's the one thing I
[ __ ] hate about the two times that I
was on Japanese TV yeah right like I
knew Japanese TV was [ __ ] scripted out
of its arse
yeah just the extent to which it is
scripted is
just ridiculous absolutely like the I
remember one time I was on this the
first time I was on the on a TV program
here in Japan was uh they did like a
street interview in Harajuku yeah and it
was like one of those it was a TV show I
was like a debate show quote-unquote
debate show where they would like gather
like 30 different foreigners from like
different countries okay and they would
put them in to a studio to basically
like there's like 30 guy James and
there's like 30 like Japanese school and
we've have to like debate on like really
like controversial [ __ ] I think one of
the topics was like should japan
legalize marijuana and like i got you
know done on the street interview and i
guess like the the crew at the time
really liked my answers that they were
like hey we might call you back and like
invite you to the actual studio because
apparently i was like the only
Australian that they ever interview so I
was like you have to come in to
represent Australia as a country cuz
like every guy's you know what
representing a different Western country
and like I said that I did a whole video
on this which went viral but like I sat
in the studio essentially and they even
like before the show started they gave
me like this full-on like like forty
page script of the entire show yeah okay
in this section the host is gonna like
call up and be like hey does anyone have
an opinion and you're the only one
that's gonna put their hand up to like
give an opinion and I'm like yeah and
they told me that five minutes before we
started filming the goddamn show so I'm
just like okay I have to remember at
allit like 1 hour and 27 minutes I have
to put my hand up to give an opinion
about the legalization of marijuana at
the end they didn't even like get to
that question Oh
literally it was like a two-and-a-half
hour recording and the whole time I just
sat this so you didn't even say anything
I didn't say anything the whole time and
they paid me 50 bucks for I sat in the
studio silently for two and a half hours
to just look pissed off because I'm
hearing these other arguments about like
why it shouldn't be legal as a why
should be legalized and it's the
like rudimentary ly basic argument that
I've ever heard yeah it's like anybody
with a [ __ ] memory it's like anybody
with a [ __ ] brain can come up with
this discussion and explain and I'm just
sitting there just angrily like waiting
for my cue and it's never going I'm just
like I really want to tell these people
to shut the [ __ ] up about the damn
awesome is not coming so slight
I even like tones of the guy in the show
you can actually see it in the show
icons of the guy on just like I'm
supposed to say something in this part
and the guys just like yeah I am too
waiting who we see next to like what
what country with a replica it was like
it was either American or Canadian it
was a Canadian guy that's wrong as a
Canadian guy and he's like yeah yeah
like I was for the legalization of
marijuana because obviously it's like
all for that he's like yes I was always
gonna say something too and after the
show we like bonded over that was just
like man [ __ ] this show they like
brought us in late they brought us in as
only two hours earlier and I'm like we
didn't have to wait this long Jesus and
it's like we basically wasted an entire
evening for me to just publicly
humiliate myself by sitting on Japanese
TV was just like the biggest resting
beach why do I get 50 bombs not a video
out of it you've got a viral video out
of it viral video we go he got peak
youtuber clickbait that's the thing
right if you if you have a shitty
situation if you can get a video out of
it the most thing is is that that video
like push me to over a million subs